I actually first started thinking about
information as a possible glimmer of an
idea for a subject for a book when I was
working on chaos that's when I first
heard about it and it was strange I was
strange to hear about information theory
as a scientific subject of study from a
bunch of physicists who were working on
chaos theory I mean they were analyzing
a physical system in fact it was chaos
in water dripping from a tap can't the
casts of a dripping faucet and they were
analyzing in terms of this thing called
information theory as invented by Claude
Shannon at Bell Labs in 1948 and I
remember thinking there's something
magical about that but also something
kind of weird about it information is so
abstract we know that there is such a
thing as information devoid of meaning
information as an abstract concept of
great use more than great use of of
fantastic power for engineers and
scientists for Claude Shannon to create
his theory of information he very
explicitly had to announce that he was
thinking of information not in the
everyday way we use the word not as news
or gossip or anything that was
particularly useful but as something
abstract a string of bits is information
and it doesn't matter whether the string
of bits represents something true or
false and for that matter it doesn't
matter whether the string of bits
represents something meaningful or
meaningless in fact from the point of
view of an electrical engineer who
believes in information theory a string
of random bits carries more information
than an orderly string of bits because
the orderly string of bits let's say
alternating ones and zeroes or let's say
not quite as ordinary not quite as
orderly a string of English text has
organization in it and the organization
allows you to predict what the next
in a given message is going to be and
because you can predict it it's not as
surprising and because it has less
surprise it carries less information
there's one of the sort of paradoxes of
of information theory that that because
information is surprise it's associated
with disorder and randomness all of this
is very abstract it's useful to
scientists it lies in the foundations of
the information based technological
world that we all enjoy but it's also
not satisfactory I think we as humans
tend to feel that this view of
information is something devoid of
meaning is unfriendly its hellish it's
it's scary it's connected with our sense
that we're we're deluge by a flood of
meaningless tweets and blogs and the the
Hall of Mirrors sensation of of
Impostors the false and and the true
intermingling we sort of we may feel
that that's what we get when we start to
treat information as something that is
not necessarily meaningful because as
humans what we care about is the meaning